so that is where we stand with that
um so that means the total i'll give you
the totals
as slow as i can so you can write them
down but then i'll give you the total
and how it affects
where the margin is right now so for
president trump 1577
for former vice president biden 1128
for joe jorgensen 43 and write-ins
7. can we look at every single ballot so
that's that's why the writings are there
i do not know those are qualified
write-ins or just
mickey mouse write-ins i i don't know
the answer to that
so when we left off the call this
morning we were looking at a margin of
13
378. the net gain for the president on
this memory card is 449
for a new total of 12 929
uh so that is where we
stand right now the situation
is because of the audit we found this we
saw some
potentials on this and again this is
where the county
had a couple places where they should
have been able to see it one the
absentee voter filed for the
reconciliation they obviously didn't do
that
to the check-ins they didn't check that
and then three the tabulator screen on
the
election management system has a box
that's checked or unchecked depending
whether the card has been uploaded or
accounted for
so there were several spots where the
human beings were running it
that didn't follow the procedure and
that's why this happens but this is why
you have the audit
to discover these things now let me
frame this up with a couple of other
items
the um we have 57 counties
that are flat out at zero deviations
from the ballot count
that they started with so that's 57 we
have 21 other counties that are either
plus one or minus one
off of the original account that they
had so that's
78 that are basically spot on
we have another 32 counties that are in
single digits that they're off
so they're finalizing that looking do
they do they miscalculate something did
they
switch data entry things along those
lines
but single digits is not that much to be
concerned about on these things but
we're trying to get it as right as we
can but to prove the outcomes are
proper and correct now again i want to
frame up
how the audit works you know we saw that
fulton was done with the audit and the
cab was done with the audit
they were done with the first phase of
the audit which is the hand accounting
then you have to go to the data entry
side where we have a lot of quality
control measures
did you put the numbers in properly did
you get
every batch did you transpose any
numbers
did you forget to put a number from the
tally sheet
into the data entry now for larger
counties there's more pieces of paper
it's going to take more time
and again as we have been saying
repeatedly
the human beings that are part of this
are the weakest link in the whole system
but that's why there's these checks and
double checks and triple checks that we
do before we finalize the audit phase of
this
and that's why this handout audit is
important
now there's one other county we have a
potential it looks like in walton county
there may be a memory card with 224
votes on it
from an election day polling location
that is still we're still trying to see
if that was a batch that might have been
missed or if there's actually a memory
card i don't have a final answer on that
yet but there could be potentially 224
votes in walton county as well
but we don't have what that is yet floyd
county
is continuing to do their scanning
and they should be done by about 6 or 6
30 and they're having to rescan
all of the early votes because at some
level they were intermingled the batches
were not
segregated from what had been scanned
before versus what happened potentially
so that's and that came through the
audit process so they had to do all of
them i think a little over eight
thousand
and then on the provisional side
they're having to rescan those at the
end of this because it looks like they
had two batches of them
and they scanned three so that'll
probably take a couple of votes away
and so i'm not sure what the final
outcome would be for floyd but they are
on a pace
they got permission from the both their
county attorney and their county
elections board to take these steps they
can recertify
either tonight or tomorrow morning and
re-upload everything they will have
those results added to
what will be the state certified results
at the end of the day
um let's see
those are the basic points we have right
now um i'll now open it up for any
questions the way we did before where
you raise your hand
and then ari or walter will ask you to
unmute and you can ask us
we need to try to do this one at a time
we'll try to get to everybody's
questions
i know there's gonna be some out there
but let's go ahead and get rolling
so who are we starting with ari or
walter
uh nick wooten okay hey gabe
hey gabe it's nick with mcclatchy um
just could you go over
exactly what happened in fayette county
and how that's different from floyd just
uh more of a developed explanation okay
for floyd county
they literally had a box of ballots that
no one even scammed
so they were off to the side
and there would never have been a record
of a tabular being produced that wasn't
accounted for so there was no
backstop because of that decision or
that lack of a decision that was made
in fayette county they had them they had
both they had them scanned
and they had the ballots they had both
sides of the equation
but in their practices at the end of
doing their reconciliation
they failed through the reconciliation
properly and we saw that there was a
already a deviation on the absentee in
person which is the early vote
and the audit confirmed it so they did
all the practices except one thing
whereas in floyd it was several things
in a secondary thing with floyd
they had had a very bad situation in the
august runoff as well so this
was a series of managerial miscues in
floyd
that was the reason it kind of rose to
that next level this is something that
we recognized we wanted to make sure it
was there before we started making
suppositions that absolutely was this
so going to the audit process allowed us
to get to that point so these were just
a portion of votes they were on this
memory card but not
uploaded to the county's electronic
results correct they had scanned them
they were ready to go they just
they didn't do the reconciliation
process properly and there was three
different ways they could have checked
and it just got by them but we saw that
there was an issue because
they had already done the check-ins into
the absentee ballot file
and then we saw the enr uploads and we
saw they were off by
about 2700 and some odd both so we said
okay
either they doubled up um check-ins for
people which doesn't make any sense
or they're missing a card so we went
through the audit process counted them
out the votes were there
and that's when we realized okay there
is a card and then they found the card
that if that kind of makes sense yeah
perfect thank you so much
okay who's next kate tobin
okay
i saw you there for a second yeah kate
you have to unmute your
phone
all right tell you let's come back um
mark nacey
yes uh thank you for doing this again um
could you have a summary of how many
counties have
completely finished their audit process
and how many counties have
not yet finished and also how many votes
have been
loaded to the state and how many are
remaining um the votes loaded in the
state we don't do this
we have the audit is a complete audit so
we don't do a partial on that
the best way i can tell you the ones i
know for sure are flat out done
are the 57 that are spot on zero right
now and the 21 that are one
up or lower some of our
um elections officials are very
perfectionist
and they want to go through and track
down those if they're for off they want
to figure out why and get to it so
they have the opportunity to do that we
have another 30 hours in the audit
so in some of the larger accounts it's
going to take more time because there's
more pieces of paper and more potential
for there to be issues that need to be
you know noodle through with the
consultants on the ground
and with the elections team that are
there in those counties
so that would be 78 probably would be a
good number to say they're flat out just
done with the whole thing
and they've got their stuff floated in
harlow and they can go to bed tonight
and sleep well and there's another 119
or so that 121 or so they still need to
keep on working
don't make me do math on the fly either
way 78
minus 159 you get the basic number
very good and i'm also interested in the
voter histories you know
that will help us do some analysis on
who voted and who didn't
are those what are history files
completely updated i see like 4.9
million records but i know in the past
sometimes we went until certification
well some of the people are still
uploading their credit for voting into
the e-net system which is a very
frustrating thing because that should
have been done
a lot earlier but we're asking a lot of
these people this year
there's been a lot on them they're
either managing a pandemic they're
managing these elections and
this new equipment and a new system that
they haven't been used to seeing before
but
now this will be the third or fourth
time they're going through it i
anticipate that we'll you will see the
final uploads
in within the next week in terms of all
people getting the credit for voting
and that's one of the issues i discussed
earlier with fulton county they were
they were behind against from that
credit for voting
and i've seen a couple other counties
that are still kind of catching up on
the credit for voting they're going
through the certificates and checking
and making sure everything got done
and finally all part of the process very
good and finally going back to our
call this morning you talked about
investigations of fulton county
is fulton county now at risk of having
to pay that 50 000
penalty that would have been abated if
it had
um i'm lacking with the order i'm not
gonna get into that right now it's a
legal question
and i i really honestly don't know um so
that's
that would be a legal question go to our
council and ryan germany
and look we're trying to work with these
counties because our main thing is
the money is that's just taxpayer money
they're just shifting from one bucket to
another
our main thing is we want to make sure
they run elections properly and well and
tightly
because we're trying to work hard to
protect the integrity of the vote
overall
all right let's try kate again
says you're unmuted kate
is your microphone on my microphone here
we go
all right there we go all right uh
i would like you uh to step us through
how you expect
events to play out on thursday and
friday
are all counties on track to upload
their data
by the deadline is there any processing
of that data that has to go on
in your office before you tell us what
happened
do you expect to have a briefing on
thursday or
friday or what do you anticipate i
anticipate that we will continue doing
these two a days until we get to the
full process and get through
certification
because we want to be as transparent as
we can to let people know what is
happening on the grounds
they have a greater faith in the outcome
at the end of the day
um the processing is still going on at
the county level they have you know like
i said a little less than 30 hours left
to get all the work done
get everything loaded to arlo for us to
get the final audit report
so then we can say that yes the outcome
of the election is the outcome of the
election
and the hope is and i said yesterday the
hope is we don't find any more of these
counties with like you know
a couple hundred here or three thousand
votes there but the reason you do the
audit is to find these kind of human
errors
and then make sure that they are
corrected so we will continue this
process we will follow the law
we will i don't see any reason why we
can't meet the midnight deadline
tomorrow
for the audit to be completed and then
working thursday and friday in our
office to make sure that all the
eyes are dotted and t's are crossed so
we can get to the final certification
because the other thing that our office
is still doing right now is building
ballots
so that we can have them out the door
ready to go for the saturday you acaba
deadline for the military and overseas
voters
that is our main goal is to make sure we
have smooth election administration
and have the proper outcomes reflected
in all these elections
thank you so much thank you okay
archeth
thanks guys hey gabe real quick um i
know this is planning the
week ahead with the fifth uh senate
runoff
what will be different in terms of what
you guys might be doing other counties
and county officials
given what you guys have seen this past
two weeks
is there something you guys have already
picked together no it won't be that much
different i mean
most accounts have executed everything
very well um
so the main things we'll be looking at
at least on the voter registration side
we want to make sure that they are
verifying people's actually
they're intending to live in the state
to make sure people understand the laws
and rules around that
um we are going to definitely go over
page 204
of the election manual showing them that
they can
look and understand when they have a
memory card that is still not accounted
for
that's a very specific thing we have in
the training
and obviously some people didn't get
that including
fayad it looks like so that's an
important bit of training we've actually
had a conversation today
with our training manager and our center
for elections director about making sure
that we really focus on that because
there's lots of tools available
to to make sure you're doing your job
right
the issue you have sometimes is people
get so caught up in doing their job
they're not checking all their boxes to
make sure
they're doing it properly just want to
get it done and as i said in our very
first press conference
speed is great we low speed we much more
prefer accuracy it's the final outcome
and that's one of the things we're going
to really hit home with everybody
but like i said we got 159 counties and
you know the vast majority are doing
everything great
thank you
okay uh zach yeah oh
thanks gabe thanks for doing this um i
think you actually kind of alluded to
this in the past answer you said you're
pretty confident you're gonna hit that
midnight deadline tomorrow of those
remaining um i'm not going to do the
math either are those remaining 70-ish
counties
is there anybody that you think that
could come kind of close to that
midnight deadline anyone that you're
concerned about or do you think that
you're all in a good shape
there's there's no way to be specific
about this because it's going through
the process that shows
if there's an issue or not i mean
granted the larger counties
have the potential for more issues just
because there's more pieces of paper
more human beings
more tally sheets and more um what do
you call it
more items to be put into date into the
data collection
bucket so the larger the county the more
likely there is to have a
some error that needs to be corrected
and found and what you want to have is
the smallest amount of errors
to be chasing as you get through this as
well i was very good
that the largest counties like dekalb
and fulton finish the physical front end
of the count
so quickly because that gives us the
time to do the quality control we need
to make sure the outcome
is actually proper and correct so
there's no way for me to say i'm
expecting this county to do better or
this county to do worse
because it's all a process and they
could have one person who
transposed numbers on a tally sheet in
you know let's say webster county
and that's a thing that has to be
corrected just as much as a person did
that on a tally sheet in fulton county
so there's no way for me to say one
county is giving me more pause than the
other at this point all the counties
have to do their jobs and they seem to
be doing them well
voting works our outside consulting
vendor on this one
feels pretty good about where we're at
right now especially like i said with
the larger counties getting the front
end of the work done
it gets them the opportunity to go
through and do the
quality control work to make sure the
outcomes are correct and there's not and
mitigate human error we can't eliminate
human error but we can mitigate human
error
who we got next uh let's see julia
hi thank you for doing another one of
these today i wanted to
get your office's response to the
release that went out from the
trump campaign this afternoon with the
subject georgia recount reveals that
president trump is right about voting
irregularities and
fraud uh saying uh he was correct to
raise these concerns that favored biden
harris
specifically uh noting the the issue in
floyd county and also taking aim
at georgia's consent decree saying that
it makes it impossible to check
uh signatures uh what is your response i
don't know if you saw the full
full i didn't see it i
actually busy doing the work of the
election precludes me sometimes from
reading the politics and the press
around some of that
um nice glasses by the way uh
the the situation we see here is
floyd county was found because of the
audit
he picked up a good chunk of votes
because of it so our process
is actually aiding him on that front but
on that side we're just trying to find
all the legal votes
and that was one that was found because
of this audit uh the consent decree
he's just wrong he's just flat out 100
foursquare wrong
uh the consent decree literally all we
did was send out an official election
bulletin
telling people hey follow our rules and
how we already do signature match
and give people a notification within 24
hours within 11 days of the election
this this it's just wrong it's confusing
to people and people want to believe it
because the president's saying it
but this consent decree literally didn't
do anything
and change the law of how we do
signature match if you look at it
it says you can match the signature back
to the the uh request
but the request was already matched to
what was on file
and what they do is they always keep the
all the signatures there
so that they can have a history of these
things one of the things we learned from
what we did we strengthened
the training from the georgia bureau of
investigations to where you say
you want to see a history if you get
more signatures you get better signature
match and that's one of the things we
did we actually strengthened signature
match not the
not the opposite of that so on that one
he's just wrong and it's just confusing
to people so i wish they would
understand what what the concentric
reaction did and what our law actually
says
and the practices that our office
actually does with with the counties
actually
this office doesn't look at signatures
counties look at signatures
and the situation we have there is that
they if there's a question
they run it up the chain and say well
what do you all think and they get extra
sets of eyes
before they would throw a potential
signature out
and like i talked to one of the
elections directors who basically says
it moves up to the registrar which is me
that this is the election they're
talking about
to look at the thing that's the final
person to say yes this either is a valid
signature or it's not and if it's not a
valid signature
if they're within 11 days that'd be in
24 hours before then that to be notified
within three days
and they have three days after the
election to cure that situation
and there's another thing i want to make
sure people understand because i've seen
this this three percent number thrown
around
as the old rejection rate what they're
doing there is they're comparing apples
and oranges the entire rejection rate is
three percent and the vast majority of
that three percent
is the ballots that show up late um if
it's just
signature match on the oath that is
point one five percent to point two
percent and that's been that way
as i said in the phone call this morning
in 16 18 and 20 is about the same
um of the 1.3 million ballots we have
this year we have 2011 that were
eventually
you know not allowed to be brought in
which is 0.15
in 2016 the last presidential election
there were 580 ballots that had a
missing or inaccurate oath which is a
signature at 246 000 which was guess
what
0.15 percent so it's they're confusing
the issue in some degree
and again they have due process through
a court of law
to try to do anything they want to we
encourage the president as people if you
have evidence and you feel like you have
a good case
bring it up to the court of law let them
do due process we're going to continue
to follow the law in our office
and the law says we're going to finish
this audit by
wednesday night we're gonna certify by
friday
okay uh next is alexa
hey i'm gabe thanks for doing this um i
just have a question about um fayette
county um
can you explain exactly you know what it
means to find a memory card i mean our
readers
um you know know that there's a paper
record of ballots so um how did they
look for the memory card as part of the
audit process or how did they even know
that was there
and what role does the memory card play
okay
during the early vote process in this
state we use what are they called the
polling place scanners
or an icp that's the dominion
letters for icp it's a polling place
scanner it's a scanner that sits on a
really big black box that's a lock box
it's the same thing we use on election
day so what happened in this particular
case
in fayette county they were given the
credit for voting appropriately in our
voter registration system
and so you can see the number of people
when you get it's absentee in person so
it's in the absentee voter files where
you see this
and when you see a person that has
submitted
their request voted and had accepted all
the same day
that is an absentee in-person voter you
can see that in the file
so we already saw that there was a
discrepancy on what was in the election
night reporting
which was about twenty seven hundred and
fifty five or twenty seven hundred off
give or take we can't be sure because
you know some some votes are skipped and
stuff
um so we saw that already so we said
okay let's just let the process move
forward
with the audit and we'll see if those
ballots are there
and sure enough when they counted the
ballots they had 2700 more than they had
on election night reporting
which matches what they had on their
check-ins
so that means that they had a scanner
that they emptied the ballots out from
but never uploaded the memory card that
had the record of those votes
so my i don't know specifically but my
assumption is i said oh
let's go look and find this memory card
they finally found the memory card and a
little baggie that has the
what which place it was and they were
able to open it and see that yes there
was these were the votes they do happen
to match up with the other
things we just counted so that's where
that came from
and that's where you take the memory
card that gets loaded into the air gap
election management system which is then
aggregated
through what they call rtr which is
results tally um
reporting and then that's taken we take
a thumb drive and get those results out
and put it into our electronic reporting
system from societal
and that's what you see on the secretary
of state's website which is the
unofficial results
so we knew that there was an issue we on
this particular one but we didn't know
exactly if they had the ballots or not
so they did
they matched the check in which then
they found the card which matches the
amounts
so the guard rails that were there
caught this and we were able to we're
going to be able to put those results
into the final amounts
and you know you hope that people do
every part of their job perfectly
in this case that did not happen like i
said there were several ways they should
have known to be looking for that card
before this process kicked off
they just failed to do that like i said
we're gonna really focus on page 204 of
the ems
training guide to make sure in the
future that doesn't happen in some of
these counties
and just as a quick thing the old ems
the gem system
had a really obnoxious color-coded thing
to let you know when you were missing a
card
it was green if you had accounted for it
it was red if you didn't
and this one it's a check box which is
still pretty clear but not as obnoxious
so maybe we'll look at making a little
more obnoxious in the future so people
will be more
you know realize that there could be a
potential card out there
just a quick question i'm follow-up do
you think
that they found did they find this
because you know they pulled out those
boxes of ballots and
were looking at the paper or did they
find it because they were
like looking at the num the list of
voters who checked in if that means well
what it was is we knew there was an
issue based on the check-in it was
verified
when we did the physical counting of the
ballots okay so they just
there is a there is a card out there
okay
thanks yeah okay
uh stephen fowler yeah hey gabe um
pretending this isn't 2020 which i know
is something we all want to do
can you contextualize this process
and how much of this is normal you know
counties tweaking results
or you know it taking two weeks for
things to be finalized can you just
put it in the context of how a normal
election post-election process looks
well let's look at it this way normally
you wouldn't have a hand count like this
and
historically in nearly every state other
than maybe florida
you have pretty wide margins so you have
counties that have
up to last friday and we kind of throw
some extra work on some of them kind of
slid over to a couple more days
to go through and do those
reconciliations make sure they have all
the ballots and all the cards accounted
for
this is for lack of a better word
normal you have 159 counties with
different levels
of resourcing and again one of the
things i said early on
in this audit process is i was less
worried about the really really big
counties because they have lots of
resources
and ability to handle some of this i
wasn't that worried about a lot of the
small counties because it was a small
amount of things that you know
a couple of people can probably manage
it was those middle counties with sort
of mid-level to low-level resources and
a decent amount of balance
was the ones we were we would see a lot
of the sliding around so
it kind of fits with the floyd and the
fayette and potentially the waltons of
the world
so that's where you see some of those
things but all of this
is normal the abnormal thing is the
presidential election is now within 12
929 votes in this state um the last time
we had one that closed was 1992.
i was uh the political director for bush
quail in 1992 so that one stings a
little bit still i think it was thirteen
thousand votes that
president clinton was elected by we had
the ross perot situation which is
another weird thing to deal with
um so again
this is all normal we are trying to get
done
accurately in a smooth orderly
methodical way so when we find some of
these things like this
you know it's irritating to a degree
because you want to be spot on as you go
but the reason you have the audit is
because human beings are going to make
mistakes
you find those mistakes and you correct
those mistakes as you go and in this
case when the margin is so narrow
every little thing matters i mean i i
can guarantee you in
18 and 16 and 14 you just keep on going
back
there's always these things that slide
around onesie twos these and stuff
and generally it's going to be smaller
on the paper on the old machines we had
it was a memory card and that was it
other than the handful
as a handful the scheme of things
um paper absentees emergency ballots
or provisionals now everything's on
paper so it's it is a different world
that our elections directors are having
to deal with
so that is a situation that changed it
up a little bit so
normal in a paper ballot environment
this is normal but this is the first
time georgia's had to deal with 100
paper ballot environment
right and then in context on that yeah
and then one more quick thing when we
talk about certification obviously with
counties you know they had to certify
that their votes were correct and things
like that but like from the state
perspective
uh what is left to do before the
secretary of state
certifies that these are the election
results well we are in the middle of a
pre-certification audit
we have to finish that audit first then
we have to go through make sure the
paperwork all
lines up with the vote totals we've seen
with the information we have in the
voter registration system
the credit for voting is there and they
essentially all balance out
we look for any discrepancies of that
front just to make sure sort of like a
last check
before you have the airplane take off um
but those are the basic things
we'll be doing as we go into the
certification process on
thursday friday uh hoping that we
hit all our marks on this audit and we
are done by wednesday at midnight
the county's work has to be done and
then the final stuff you know going into
thursday morning we have to get the
report out from the arlo system
but again i still feel confident that we
will
meet those goals hit that certification
and get those ballots out the door for
military and overseas voters on saturday
okay lecrae is next
hi thanks for doing this again um i just
wanted to
re if you could remind me is there any
penalty associated with the counties not
having
this done by midnight wednesday and
also if it is the case that a county
doesn't finish by then
does that mean that we could potentially
still find
ballots that were not properly
reconciled in other counties too
there's always that possibility until
we're done there's
if they don't make the deadline of
midnight on wednesday there is
potentially things under the seb rules
that we can then
look at fining or giving a letter of
instruction but look this isn't about
punishing people this is about getting
it right and setting deadlines and
meeting deadlines
so our hope is we can work with the
counties get them the resources they
need to finish this up in an appropriate
way so we can get the accurate
results finalized in to our election
management system so that we can certify
the election results by friday
emile moffatt hey gabe you said you had
an
inkling that something was a little off
with the numbers in fayette
um are you seeing anything else around
the state that kind of
is similar to that not that i'm aware of
right now but it doesn't mean it doesn't
exist uh that was one that we saw it was
when you look at the reports you get
from that out of the absentee ballot
report it was kind of
it was too large to just be it could
have been a data error but that would
mean there'd be like there'd be lots of
individual data errors
and it made us think there might be one
of those we figured we'd go through the
audit process to
verify what we were looking at and as it
did it did match up
and that's when we knew the card was
there and i don't know the individual i
don't know the timeline
who found it when but i do know they saw
this discrepancy and they said okay
there has to be a card and then they
found the card
so that's that's kind of where that went
down and the single digit just a quick
follow-up the single-digit uh
differences we're seeing in the majority
of counties uh who've
finished their process so far
majority let's see 57 of them all right
no
discrepancy let's be clear so the 110 57
are at zero right now on the discrepancy
side okay for those
those in the single digits um you
believe those
are um errors slight errors and not
ballots that have been that have been
that were uncounted
yeah because in some cases they went up
by one ballot or down by one ballot
and they could have gone up by one
ballot because you know two absentee
ballots got
stuck together when it went through the
scanner i mean there's no real way to
necessarily know for certain or
a human being did a stack of eleven one
should have been a stack of ten
i mean that's that's the kind of thing
you see when you're down to the single
digit kind of things
thanks uh
joan hi hi
gabriel thank you for doing this i'm
with the ipad types
i actually have a question we heard that
counties don't
tabulate their own vote totals even in
the hand counting process because
they uploaded them to the arlo system
and then the arnold system run by the
secretary state office
tells them their totals so in other
words we
um secret uh like a local counties don't
calculate they are final
vote totals um in the local office
is that understanding correct no
um what we're seeing in arlo they're
only looking at the presidential race
they still have all the stuff that to
put into our normal election management
system
and to the normal election night
reporting system on my side
so in this particular case most counties
are keeping their own spreadsheet or
their talent sheets because they have
the physical tally sheets on those
they put it into our loan arlo is just
doing a measurement to say
this is the appropriate outcome for this
race and we're not using
these results to certify we're using
these results to verify
the results we saw of election night in
our election management system
as reflected in the election not
reporting so the final thing that we
certify
is going to be those results that are
tallied together inside the 159
um election management systems
individually and they're sending to our
system
when we do what we call the ballot run
which is where we have to get the
physical
jump drives and paperwork to go with
those to get our certified results
finished up so that's how that all kind
of comes together
for the final version of the final final
numbers but now
arlo has nothing to do with our
certification other than it's the tool
that we use
to run the pre-certification art
does that help you
joan okay
uh who's next
uh julia
julia i muted oh you're still muted
sorry sorry
sorry um just quick thing sorry if i if
i
missed this somehow do you have any i
know that as of 11am there were 300 000
ballots left to count
um is there any update on that number
and then just to follow up on my
my earlier question about the trump
campaign's message just in general when
you're seeing these
these accusations of voter fraud in
georgia as a result of some of these
discrepancies do you feel like it's on
the secretary of state's office
to be more uh kind of public messenger
about
why it's not fraud and
kind of convincing some of these critics
uh that it that is not the case as
you've outlined
here i think that we've been pretty
apparent that we do not see
widespread voter fraud in the state that
there will be illegal votes we know that
we're tracking those down
but i think uh the secretary i think
every time i
been in front of the cameras i've been
very clear we've not seen widespread
voter fraud
um we do know this will be illegal
voting but it's going to be
down in the low hundreds not in the 12
929 range we have no reason to believe
we've seen anything like that but we
will investigate everything
um like i said we opened up two other
investigations this morning in fulton to
go over
specific things some relating to some of
these charges to you know either confirm
or deny
the outcomes on those so that's what
we've been doing i think we've been very
clear that we have not seen
rampant voter fraud in this state and if
anybody has evidence of that as i said
and i suggested
there is due process in this country
there is a system of courts where you
can take
your grievances and take your evidence
but this
office will continue to follow the law
which is means right now we go through
the process
of doing this risk limiting audit which
turned into a hand audit which will be
completed on wednesday night
and then we'll move the certification
process which we need to complete by
friday in order to do our duty to get
the ballots out to our military and
overseas voters on saturday
well that's all we've got
everybody oh wait i think julia wanted
to uh
follow up i saw him i looked like a gang
sign for a hashtag i didn't know what
that was yeah sorry i was reminding you
of the number
of the balanced account i was looking
online i was waiting to get a report
from the voting works folks i'll spend
volunteering we're probably a 4.8
million right now
um only because there's works being done
to try to
balance everything out and see where
they're at but i do know that like
chatham is still counting and gwinnett
is still counting so those are the
biggest buckets to get us over that five
million mark that are still out there
got it and sorry one last thing just to
clarify are are the results of the
manual recount in the official
presidential race tally
that will be made public right do you
have a timeline for that or
our intent is this audit
verifies the outcome of the of the stuff
that we loaded through our election
management system
and was basically shown on election
night reporting and we will be
certifying
what comes out of our election
management system it's precinct based
the our low number is just to verify
the outcome now we will make that public
we will show every county result we will
show every
you know battle that they were off we
will all that we publicly will put
the tally sheets pdfs for those scanned
in
to um so that everybody can go review
everything i mean we're trying to be as
transparent as we can but all that
information will be released
i don't have a timeline because there's
going to be thousands of pieces of paper
we're trying to figure out how do we
organize and put it on a website that
makes
rational sense to navigate but that we
do intend to do that as quickly as we
can
we'll probably do a release on the
numbers and probably get county level
results with a spreadsheet attached as a
starting point
so that y'all have information you need
to tell your viewers and your readers
i guess listeners too for the radio
folks out there okay thank you
all right who else without anybody i saw
emma jones jones
that's another question okay yeah it's
just a follow-up question and gab thank
you for doing this again
um so i guess maybe a lot of people they
are concerned about using the
uh computer system and to even just to
save the data
how would the secretary state office
make sure there's no glitches
in the computer system which well the
easiest thing to do is the fact that um
all election management systems and
every piece of our equipment
that's done for for voting and talenting
voting is air gap which means that it's
not touching the internet
so that's that's one of the biggest
things we talk about in our
voter registration system is put on a
various we just rebuilt and put it
putting into a very secure
um new server environment and we have we
have partnerships with department of
homeland security to keep an eye on
these items
and you might have seen that the
homeland security
and especially the cyber infrastructure
security agency
put out this was the single most secure
election in the history united states
we absolutely know this is the single
most secure election in georgia
there is no you know hammer and
scorecard it doesn't exist it's not real
anybody telling you that you know the
discount
their their what they're saying there's
just zero evidence it doesn't exist
and all it does is undermines people's
confidence in the outcome so the biggest
thing is
our systems are air gaps which means
they're not on the internet so nobody
can do anything on that fund
and then the voter registration system
which is the secondary another system as
part of that
is put in a very secure environment we
have partnerships with homeland security
we have outside vendors that do
penetration testing
we look for vulnerabilities at all time
because when you're dealing in cyber
security environment
it is a never-ending race and we know
that we're always going to be
very leery of that especially going into
this this january 5th runoff
there used to be 50 targets in 50 states
now there's gonna be one target here for
people to try to
make mischief on that stuff but we see
more problematically
from both foreign actors and some
internal here people who are supplying
disinformation and disinformation
is kind of eats away it's corrosive to
everybody's belief in the in the system
the outcomes of these elections so
our system is very secure you can always
work to make everything more secure with
time
and effort and money and resources and
we will always be continuing to do that
to improve on what we have done so far
but
we've really focused on that in this
office over the last two years basically
walter what else we got uh that's it
that's all the hands that are up
all right so it's 4 45 i think we'll be
doing this again tomorrow at 11.
i believe uh just keep an eye out that
those potentially can
based on you know other information is
happening and
there is actual work we have to do but
one of the most important things we can
do is to continue to inform you all
so you can inform the public of what's
actually going on in georgia and give
you as much reality check as we can
on the system we remain transparent we
remain dedicated to the rule of law we
remain dedicated to the process this is
process
process process we will continue to
follow those rules those laws
and if anybody has a specific issue they
want to address
there is a court of law take it to them
this this is the opportunity i mean
it's it's coming very soon that
everything will be done here and we will
be able to move on to the next round of
elections which is our january 5th
elections which is very important we
execute those properly as well so
with that i say have a good night and if
you've got any other questions
circle back up or walter or aria we'll
try to get you the answers thanks a lot
you